en France le reste de l'actualité avec
tout d'abord l'affaire Grégorie épilogue
judiciaire puisque la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de Dijon
doit se prononcer sur la culpabilité de
Christine villemain 8 ans après les fait
le procureur général lui s'est prononcé
pour un nonlieu c'est-à-dire l'innocence
le reportage de José
gonzalz une fois encore Jean-Marie et
Christine Vilmain doivent se frayer un
chemin entre la quarantaine de
journalistes présents une nouvelle fois
Christine Vilmain doit se présenter
devant des magistrats après 8 ans
d'instruction mais peut-être est-ce pour
elle la dernière fois l'avocat général
demande le non lieu pour la mèire du
petit Grégori la défense de Jean-Marie
et Christine Vilmain est d'accord bien
sûr mais France I Lauren le révélit
jeudi dernier la partie civile Albert et
Monique Vilmain parents de Jean-Marie
grands-parents de Grégorie souhaitent un
supplément d'information objectif
utiliser un ordinateur récemment mis au
point très performant pour comparer la
voix enregistré du corbeau qui menaçait
la famille avec celle de toutes les
personnes impliquées dans le dossier y
compris Christine Vilmain or aujourd'hui
et on ne les compte plus coup de théâtre
en ce qui concerne le nonlieu de
Christine villemain il y avait si j'ose
dire l'union sacrée l'union sacrée entre
la partie civile le ministère public et
la défense l'union sacrée en clair les
grands parents renoncent à utiliser ce
nouvel ordinateur pour comparer entre
autres la voix de Chr
il sou que jean-mie soit jugé le plus
vite possible et il P que dans
l'immédiat c'est prématuré que
Jean-Marie a téléphon à s parents c'est
ce que nousens d'ailles c'est un secret
pour personne il sont réconciliés et
nous rien qui aille contre les intérês
Jem les magistrats dij vont donner le
temps de la réfleion l'affaire sera mise
en délibér Christine V inculpé pour le
meurtre de son fils depuis le 5 juillet
85 devra attendre quelques semaines
encore M